Yes! Yes, man!
Thank you very much!
Welcome to The Nightly Show!
-Man! What a great crowd today.
-(audience chanting "Larry!")
Thank you. I appreciate it.
I appreciate it.
Uh, you guys,
you got to get together on that
though.
'Cause he was like, "Lar-ry!"
He was like,
"Yo, man, it's 'Larry!'"
Happy International Women's Day
out there to everybody,
I just want to say. Happy
International Women's Day.
Very cool.
Um, and also, you know,
this is one of those days...
I don't know how to start...
You know, I'll tell you what,
I just want to take a moment
to acknowledge, um, a loss
in the comedy community.
And, um,
I know this happened last week,
but it's-it's just taken me
a few days to process.
REPORTER: Retired neurosurgeon
Ben Carson has pulled out
of the Republican race.
Carson announced
that he was suspending
his campaign
at a gathering in Maryland
on Friday.
That's right, you guys.
That's right.
Black Droopy the Dog
has officially put his campaign
to bed.
(as Droopy): "Would you believe
I'm suspending my campaign?
"I wanted to be
the real black president.
That's bull(bleep)."
-(applause) -And, uh...
Thank you very much. Thank you.
And although we'll mourn
his sleepy, stabby tirades,
uh, Ben Carson may not
be gone forever, you guys.
Technically, he didn't quit--
he suspended his campaign.
I mean, maybe he'll take
another stab at it
as Kanye's running mate in 2020,
you know?
Ben-ye 2020, y'all.
That's all I'm sayin'.
But you know what, here's the
thing, it also made me think,
why do candidates suspend
their campaigns
instead of just quitting,
anyway?
I'll tell you what,
to break it down and give us
his expert analysis, here's
rapper 2 Chainz in a segment
we call 2 Chainz Explainz.
WOMAN:
♪ 2 Chainz Explainz ♪
(cheering and applause)
Hi. I'm 2 Chainz.
And suspending your campaign
is all about the money, Larry.
See, if you suspend
your campaign instead of quit,
you can still raise money
from suckers that don't know
you dropped out the game.
Then the federal government
will give you matching dollars
for those same funds.
So you can stack your money,
stack your money, and stack your
money until you need a ladder,
and then your campaign
is out of debt.
See, as of last month, Wisconsin
Governor Scott Walker's campaign
still owed vendors $1.2 million.
That's half the cost
of my chains, man.
You know how I go.
"All my broads is foreign.
All my money tall like Jordan."
You kind of get where I'm going
with this stuff, right?
-True!
-All right.
This has been 2 Chainz Explainz,
you guys.
WOMAN:
♪ 2 Chainz Explainz ♪
Make sure to pick up 2 Chainz's
new album ColleGrove
with Lil Wayne, available now
wherever records are sold.
I'm assuming online somewhere.